[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 45th
episode of my dirty chest tricks in this
episode I'm going to reveal GM Hikaru
Nakamura's tricky pet line against kings
in interference from the right
perspective the most amazing part I
found about this trick is recently there
are three super grandmasters fall into
it and that is to say even in the same
tournament haha isn't that amazing in
the two now in practice if you find out
that your opponent is playing Kings
Indian defense against d4 and n f3 then
you can literally use this line as a
complete surprise weapon the best part
is the critical position can be reached
why are three different openings let's
say you can either start with the move B
3 d 4 or in this game against Anna's
giddy he start with the move Knight to
f3 Knight to f3 has a married that it
completely stopped ePHI by white and the
typical kings in in position can be
arise while this model Knight to f6 b3
g6 Bishop to b2 Bishop to g7 III Castle
on the Kings side and now the move d4
now as I have highlighted over here
black has plenty of choices he can
continue it either to move d6 or defy as
well as b6 but the second most popular
choice by black is c5 which in fact in
the online database there are more than
400 games played with this move and it
looks very natural because it undermined
the white center
except that is one problem that it's
straightaway lead to Nakamura's Patrick
which start with D cap to c5 grabbing
the c5 pawn and now the main move over
here is Queen - if I check Black has
some other tries to regain the pawn but
I don't think so they are working for
example if he continued with Knight to
e4 then the simplest continuation is you
capture this mission and after King
takes you deliver this check so by force
black has to put his knight back on have
sex afterwards we can calmly develop our
King side piece with Bishop to e2 the
whole point is after Knight to c6 and
Queen to be - we are maintaining that
pain and same time remain solid pawn up
and if black still insists to grab the
pawn with the Queen Jack then our Queen
can slide back to c3 and Black has
nothing better than capturing this Queen
afterwards
Knight capture C three lives white a
very healthy pawn and in fact a better
winning chances well the same goes for
the Moon Knight to e6
it looks like it's attacking the pawn
but it helps Y to complete his
development with the move Bishop
captures e6 if pawn captures then black
pawn structure will be ruined
so that's not the idea Black's main
point is he wants to deliver this check
and then take back with the Queen
okay no problem what he's going to
defend the check with Knight - D - and
after Queen captures a6 which time being
stopping the castle but this is just an
illusion as after the move fo you can
see I have highlighted simple plant by
white he wants to play Queen - E - and
then launch with b4 b5 and frankly
speaking I don't see any compensation
for the black camp
so to cut the long story short the only
move here for the black is to play queen
- if I check and then regained upon this
way okay white will continue with the
Moose III and finally released with a
critical position of this line where
mainly Black has two options first let's
look at what happened if black routinely
captured on c5 which is initial no in
this position but it turns out that this
is a big mistake
and this is where Nakamura's home
preparation comes into the picture
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out what is wrong
with Queen capture CFI well I hope you
do find this wonderful move Bishop to e3
BAM hahahaha so this Bishop is attacking
the Queen and unfortunately Queen
doesn't have the square of D 6 and ePHI
to guard the e7 pawn and that means the
e7 pawn is a goner before I move on I
like to mention one important point that
I have covered the full game in the PGN
which later on you can check it out in
this video I'm going to stop where white
get the upper hand in the first game
against Mama djaro black continue with
Queen to b6 which is a great deal of
inaccuracy and here white cement his
advantage with Bishop captures a 7
attacking the rook rook to e8 and now
the very simple move Bishop captures f6
Bishop captures f6 and now Bishop to e2
Knight to c6 and castle on the Kings
side
so after the whole sequence it turns out
that on the twelfth move of the game
white emerged with an extra pawn and yes
you can argue their black has a bishop
pair but he also has a weak isolated D
pawn which can be the major factor in
the rest of the game from here onwards
nakamura converted the full point within
30 hit moves in the second game his
opponent
super grandmaster Wesley soo played an
accurate move Queen to c7 and after the
move Bishop to e7 black has two choices
the older move Knight to e4 turns out as
a big time mistake by black and after
this in all the lines by force white is
spinning the accurate sequence start
with Bishop captures a fade grabbing the
rook without any fear and ask black to
do your vast on c3 if night cap to c3
here then the simplest move is Queen to
d6 attacking to sports
so black responses force he has to
capture on d6 afterwards we will take
back and no matter wherever this Knight
moves this Bishop will block the
diagonals and at the end white will
emerge with an extra piece well what
about Bishop capture c3 more or less
same story as white is going to capture
this mission and after Queen capture c3
white has the only move but it is more
than enough to win the game and that is
Knight to detune black doesn't have time
to capture this bishop because then look
to see one will appear on the board and
black will instantly get the losing
position so the forcing sequence
continued with Knight captures d2 idea
is you cannot capture the night as the
rook in the corner hangs but White has a
nice intimate
and that is rook to Sivan and no matter
how evil black wriggles he cannot get
out of this mess the best he can do is
give this double check but then once
again white can fearlessly put his King
on e2 and asking black do you have
enough for today so accordingly Wesley
so rightly played the move rook to e8
attacking the bishop but as from the
last game you know the outcome yup
it's bishop gets his f6 Bishop captures
f6 and now the simple move Knight to d4
and we have the same scenario where
whitey merge with an extra pawn and a
centralized night where black has a
bishop pair and a weak isolated pawn
which is not a great deal of
compensation for losing upon last but
not least what happens if black
continued with rook to e8 which is a
case of Nakamura and GD so black is
becoming smart now he wants to capture
on c5
but why it says nope sweetie you don't
have that time as I'm going to
consolidate my phone with the move B for
a super pawn chain on the Queen side and
after gay is queen to c7 we have a
unique scenario where White has a
reverse slow gambit structure and
generally black get a very good counter
play with the moon a fine b6
if white tried to consolidate his extra
pawn with a3 and night to d2 however
Nakamura shows us a dynamic way to play
such position has he continued with c4
so not only this Bishop is open up but
against all counter play by black such
as Knight to c6 or a fi White has a very
comfortable answer so let's see it
the first move Knight to c6 is bit
inaccurate as after the following
sequence a three supporting one before
fi hitting before one more time
white can still defend with Queen to b3
and now you understand the problem in
the black camp in order to free up this
Bishop black has to somewhere down the
line play the move b6 or d6 and in
either case let's say d6 white will
capture this pawn and after quintics
and the Moose ePHI apart from the pawn
advantage I think these positions are
fun to play as a white okay then how
about a 5 immediately hitting before and
this is what happened in the game but
nakawara shows us how easily he get
advantage after a 3a captures before a
captures before rook exchange and after
the obvious move Knight to a6 attacking
on b4 white if wish can't continue with
Bishop to c3 where he is a healthy pawn
up but nakamura is a very ambitious
player and he choose the another
aggressive alternative namely Bishop to
e5 and after d6 pawn takes pawn takes
and now we have dropped back to c3 the
only difference it makes is it weakens
more porn on the Queen side which held
white to create attack on those juicy
squares that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn this wonderful tricky line of
nakamora
against Kings Indian remember if you
opponent continue with the C file then
full point is awaiting on the board
thank you for watching this feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care